vo this is Mike Raleigh North Carolina
Big Mike over there in Raleigh and
Raleigh Coleman was a UH assistant
principal at one of my schools and he
used to sleep in his car at lunch and he
would deny but I saw him get in there a
couple time and kind of closed the thing
and he dressed in there and he had a
little thing he would tie it off and
just breathe out the UM about a keyhole
he would take the key piece off and
breathe through there put his mouth
about air on the inside and breathe
through there and sometimes take one of
them little a sac milk in there with him
wandering him sac milks you put that
straw in even just Dexter that [ __ ] and
then hit it
remember those but uh and he also was
some time where roller skates at lunch
and do a little athletics but go on
homework not really a hot topic or
anything starts kind of crazy story I'm
going to ever heard a surprise babies
story but the day after the fourth of
July we had a baby boy and we had no
idea that was coming she's personal test
back in November all came back not
pregnant she was having her cycle or hit
her every month
oh yeah that Tony Gwynn baby baton for
the cycle bruh
it's like a brother gets loose inside of
your woman brought out Tony Gwynn and
they start acting wild you know and they
started just really just just really
acting wild he never kicked one time and
fourth of July she thought she was
constipated all day long I was driving
around gonna go to a pool party
listening to King in this thing and you
know she says she's got time to play
didn't feel good so we were gonna go to
the ER together and she ended up going
home going to sleep so I was just
waiting get that calls you on the go but
I never got a call went by her apartment
car was gone
called the hospital said that were
getting a scan transported there and
came by her dad was outside waiting for
me say I was gonna be a daddy she was in
labor and I think it's funny man you
know some people in there when they're
pregnant give him all the the paid tobin
but the baby and the woman with all this
stuff my kid was listening to this past
weekend King understanding that
congratulations like Chris D'Elia
Oh God sorry about that
I hope the kid will be okay homework
I thought you think that's cool man
maybe they'll grow up to be a comedian
one day that's off the a man Gang Gang
Gang Gang bruh he might be a comedian he
might also grow up you know to be a mime
I mean I Do's must be hella quiet if
nobody even knew he was in their body
for nine months
think about it if I got something in my
body for nine months and it doesn't make
a peep that's not even a baby man I say
ninja your wife had a ninja so you might
want to give that thing a piece of cat
of you know a big piece of pound cake or
a big turkey leg or a cotton candy
because you got that low key that secret
Asian baby
that's a damn ninja dude if you didn't
dude I never go into the toilet and come
back a parent I mean nice Dark Arts
brother you know and God bless you guys
with the new baby and I'm so excited for
you but I never you know I never been
over it you know at a chick's house and
she busts a fart or something or a
little bit of body gas and next thing
you know I'm a stepfather so I don't
know what's going on but y'all might
need to get on keto or y'all might need
to get on armed you might need to get a
sonogram at the house brother y'all you
know what I'm saying you got to know
when you just got to know if something's
living inside of your body I think I
guess or maybe you don't you know what
actually bruh this sounds great you
didn't have to spend any money on the
baby shower you didn't have to paint the
room or do all of that dude if this baby
can be quiet for nine months inside of a
woman's body he can sleep in a garage he
could sleep in a [ __ ] in one of the
dEWALT's in the truck dude it's big you
could put his baby anywhere do you could
put this baby in a glove box baby leave
him in there overnight put a sack milk
in there with him like your boy Raleigh
Coleman so look man I think you need to
write a book on how to have that zero
dollar baby because you heard a million
dollar baby Hilary Swank but you never
heard of uh
of uh of the of $0 baby that's what you
got to write how to have a baby $0 zero
sign of grams no baby clothes silent
baby baby you got them you got a damn
mine brother and congratulations man I'm
happy that you're fathering is something
your wife is doing okay and and you know
it sound like y'all beautiful over there
and and uh and thank you for sharing
that remarkable story that's remarkable
Jesus